today is going to be a bit special
because today's
video is a reaction video we will
together look at a video from one of the
very large
content creators in the sphere of
consulting out there her name is kate
choi
i trust that many of you have already
come across of some of her videos i
believe she does great content on the
topic of consulting i inserted a link to
the channel below in the video
description so check it out if you want
to see more
in the video we're going to talk about
today she is talking about the pros and
cons of consulting from her perspective
and i believe that consulting is a very
heterogeneous field with lots of
different types of firms present so
while now watching the video i will
frequently stop
and share my experiences as a former
mckinsey consultant
i will reflect on what she is saying and
then give you my perspective on whether
i believe that this is also true
for an mbb context or where there might
be some differences so trust this is
really going to be valuable for you if
you are asking yourself whether
consulting is the right career choice
for you to pursue so welcome on my
channel firm learning but now without
further ado
let's jump into it the first pro is that
when you're a consultant you usually get
to work in
a lot of different industries this is
great if you don't have a particular
interest or passion in one industry
whether that's healthcare or consumer
goods or anything like that
because in consulting you usually get
access and
opportunities in all different kinds of
industries
so let me start here what she says is
that usually as a consultant you get
access to lots of industries
and of course this is true and this is
correct in general
do be mindful here which consulting firm
exactly you are joining
and just as in one example in germany
there exists
the large consulting firm roland berger
and their structure is that they are
structured in different
competence centers and the usual way
to enter to start working at
wollenberger is that from the beginning
you directly to commit
to one of these competence centers and
then in most cases at least this is my
understanding
you will work the majority of your time
for the industry of the competence
center that you are part of
i understand that there are also some
opportunities to start as a generalist
at roland berger
but this is just one example then there
are others as well
for instance at oliver wyman as far as
i'm informed there's a financial
services arm
if you join there then you will be
dedicated to the financial services
practice so inform yourself
really make sure that you understand
what the company really is doing
obviously
before you start there this is something
i really appreciate about my job because
i always get to be learning new things
now the flip side or the con to this
is that you can tend to become a
generalist in
lots of different industries and not
have a particular expertise in any
single one
over time it is possible and normal to
gain an expertise in a particular
industry
or issue but that obviously takes some
time so at least in the beginning so
here i would say at least based on my
experience at mckinsey i'd say it's kind
of
right and wrong at the same time it's
right in the sense that of course in the
beginning
you will not be a super deep expert in
one specific topic and it takes some
time as she's also saying
and yes if you really switch industry to
industry
then will be quite hard for you and will
take some time until you really
gain this deep industry expertise but
the other side of things is that
especially if you decide to early on
pursue projects that are specifically in
one industry only
or at least the majority of projects in
that specific industry
i would argue that you will build
industry expertise much quicker and much
more deeply than you would in an
average corporate role in that industry
and the reason is that
you will do projects in all different
types of companies of that industry
seeing lots of different functions in
the industry
working together with very senior
employees
of that industry and i trust this is
really the accelerated type of
career development and experience and if
you want to try to get a similar
experience like that
in industry if you just start in one of
a normal industry role
in that industry this will be difficult
and it will take you
much longer so from that sense i would
argue
that actually in consulting you can gain
and collect that industry experience
much more quicker than if you would just
start in an average corporate role in
part of your career and at least for the
first several years you're probably
going to be working in an array of
industries
rather than focusing in on a single one
depending on the firm you're at so maybe
you're at a consulting firm that has a
very specific focus but in general as a
consultant you're working
from industry to industry so you tend to
get
a little bit of a surface level
knowledge across all different kinds of
industries the second
and here i just want to add or just kind
of sharpen your perception
that it's really important what your
consulting background is of
what type of consulting firm you're
coming from
and i think what's important to
understand is that kate choi as far as i
understand her profile
she is coming from a rather boutique
type of consulting firm she's coming
from a change management consulting firm
and firms like that focus on really one
specific
topic in that case change management if
no this is accurate how i see you know
her profile
and this now is to be contrasted with
firms like mbb
or even other like large strategy
consulting firms also tier two
strategy consulting firms that have a
much broader
perspective of tasks that the work so
the types of projects that you will do
will be much broader which will help you
to gain a much
more deep understanding of a certain
industry second pro which is related
is that you get to work on lots of
different projects so not only do you
get to work in different industries and
with different companies but you also
get to do different projects as in
solve different issues for them in the
video that i mentioned at the beginning
of this video i sort of break down what
those different issues are so you can
check that out to learn a bit more for
me i work on multiple different projects
for different clients at the same time
there are other consultancies where you
are on one project for a set number of
months
just to add in here now from the mbb
perspective
here in the first years you will always
like
99 of the times you will be dedicated to
one
project you will not work a different
project since parallel
this only starts once you are a senior
project lead once you want to make the
transition to become a junior partner
this is then when you start maybe
leading and being responsible for two or
three projects in parallel
but this is now a step in the career
that is many years down the line
so in the first three four or five years
this is not what will happen you will be
dedicated to one project
and at least now relative to the types
of projects that you will do in mbb
it would also time wise be completely
impossible
to different projects or many projects
in parallel regarding your time budget
this just would
not be feasible but either way you get
to switch out your projects and
do something a little new every single
time the con is that naturally you're
gonna like
some projects more than others so you're
gonna have some ups and downs in terms
of how much you're enjoying your work
you might be staffed on a project for
three months that you absolutely love
and then the next one comes along and
it's a six month project
that you're just not as passionate about
or excited about as you move
yes i can fully agree with that that is
completely accurate for sure
doesn't matter to what consultant you
talk to everybody will confirm that
there are some projects that they really
liked
and then there are some projects that
were really bad for all kinds of reasons
right this is completely normal
but here i'd say the positive if now i
compare that to a corporate job
there it's even more digital right i
mean either you get along with your team
you get along with your boss
you like your work or you end up
actually not liking it
but what you do in a corporate role if
you don't like it then pretty much the
only
choice that you have is either to
transition within the company if that is
even possible
or really need to quit your job or look
for something else but the positive
thing in consultant from my perspective
at least is that
yes maybe there was a bad project which
went on for a couple of months which you
really disliked
but then this project will be over then
you can now completely
go out there on a new choice you can go
on a new project you can work together
with new people
and then over time you get to know the
people that you really enjoy working
with
you better understand for yourself what
the projects are that you enjoy doing
and then can actively start to pursuing
these types of projects
and these types of colleagues more and
more move up in your career and gain
more experience then you can start to
not only gain more expertise in a
specific area
but also have more of a say in the
projects that you're on but when you're
first starting out and in those first
several years
you have to work a little bit harder to
get the projects that you want to get
also completely agree on that so the
staffing market what she's referring to
right so the
options of projects that you have they
very much depend on your internal
reputation
so the more you are considered as a rock
star
as a high performer the more people will
want to work with you
so maybe the better choices you have and
now you want to choose your project
and of course at the beginning nobody
really knows you you're kind of one of
many new associates
and then you kind of need to earn and
develop your reputation over time and
this will then take some time until you
have developed that
but then once you did it will
significantly help you to then really do
only and specifically the projects that
you want to do
third pro is travel now not all
consultants travel because you might
have some that are based in a particular
office
and all the clients are local so there
isn't much traveling going on but a lot
of consultants do have to travel around
the u.s or even
internationally to meet with their
clients sometimes you'll get staffed on
a project that is in a really cool place
but i would actually say that the pro
from this
is not so much the travel itself but the
rewards
and the status that you get from all
that travel personally
that is completely accurate so i have a
whole wallet
just of bonus cards of all kinds of
hotel chains and airlines
you know you have like all these gold
platinum
diamonds status cards from all these
different chains
and then this is something that you can
also leverage for your private for your
personal vacations right because
then of course you will be treated
accordingly in these institutions
when you use that for private reasons as
well so yes these are perks
of being consulted this is correct most
of my projects are
based in the us and so i've done travel
to nashville
houston philadelphia kind of all over
the u.s
and not so much internationally yet i'm
definitely always expressing my interest
at work and traveling internationally
for a project
so hopefully something will come up that
is the right fit but usually when i have
a work trip and i'm traveling for
client work i'm just there like the
night before a meeting
then go to the meeting in the morning
and then i'm flying back home that
evening so there isn't usually that much
time to do
any actual exploring or traveling but
because of all the travel
that i do i gain status with my
preferred airline and hotels so you just
get to
reap the benefits of yeah so here she
just said that she pretty much
you know start in the morning flying
somewhere and then in the evening she
flies out
so this is not really the rhythm that
you will have on your average mbb
project and a normal mbb project and of
course here there are also some changes
but usually you will fly in on monday
morning
and then fly out on thursday evening
this is kind of your standard
work week and then within the work week
like monday to thursday
you will stay at the client work client
side
and then usually stay at a hotel the
only exception of course is if you do a
project
in your hometown and then of course you
can just work or stay at home then in
the evening and then on top of that you
might fly out to even other locations
maybe you have a workshop within the
week in another city
in another country maybe even in another
continent so this is then the travel
that even comes on top of that
but kind of the baseline is staying
monday to thursday at your client
that like upgrades and things like that
it also means that i can rack up
miles and be able to make trips based
solely on my miles so i'm paying nothing
or just paying like a five dollar fee to
book a plane ticket the only con i would
say that comes with traveling for work
is that it is much harder to
gain a healthy work-life balance it can
be hard to get into a routine
for example meal prepping is pretty
impossible to do
if your schedule is constantly changing
or even if you're a consultant who
travels from monday to thursday
then you're only home for a few days out
of the week so you tend to do things
like
going out to eat instead of prepping
your meals and things like that also
when you i just want to
stress and underline this because here
again i completely agree
and the problem is that in most cases
monday morning you will need to wake up
really early to get one of the earlier
flights so depending a bit on your
location the connection
often you will need to wake up at 5am
sometimes even earlier
so this means you already start your
work week with some kind of sleep
deficit
and then this just continues building
over the work week and then usually on
thursday evening
or then when the week is over you really
need to do lots
of sleeping on the weekend to recover of
course now a bit depending on your
individual sleep needs but this then
leads to really don't having that much
time also not on the weekends
and this is of course why this travel
can be quite a burden and adds to the
not so ideal work-life balance for many
projects when you travel a lot for work
your work time and personal time tend to
blend together a lot for example
sometimes i need to book a flight that
doesn't get me home
until 11 30 at night which means a lot
of my personal time has been taken up by
work pro number four
is that you get to work with a lot of
big companies often fortune 100
companies that
are really cool and well-known that
means you might get to go to the
headquarters of a really well-known
company meet with
leaders there and it's just really cool
that you get to help
shape companies that are so well known
across the world
i agree with that this is indeed what
you will frequently do
and of course you also depends a bit on
your taste so for me personally
one of the best experiences i had was
rather working for
some more medium sized companies in
consulting not necessarily the very big
corporates
and the main reason being that there
sometimes at least i
felt like the possibilities that you
have the things that you can really
change
the time to impact the path to impact
was even shorter was even more direct
but now this might also be a question of
personal preference
so yes of course you will work with very
large clients and you will meet lots of
senior executives this way
con is that those companies and clients
could be a lot more demanding this is
really a generalization because some
people
and clients you'll just get along with
better on a personal level
just because your working styles or your
personalities match so regardless of the
company there are going to be some
clients
that are more demanding or more
difficult to work with and others that
are a little easier to work with but i
would say that the bigger the client or
more well-known the client
is there's just that much more pressure
to make sure you're performing and
bringing results and pro
so here i'd say i didn't see that
correlation that strongly right i had
great clients to work with at very large
companies that
are super difficult people to work with
at smaller companies
but overall i agree that you know the
type of clients you have or you can work
together with them
really shapes your experience and it can
be really hard as a consultant
if you just don't get along well with
your clients so this is for sure a very
decisive factor pro number five
is that the compensation or the pay is
usually pretty good
according to glassdoor the average
salary for a consultant in the us
is about 79 000 which when you compare
to a salary for
a software engineer for example is
actually kind of low but when you look
at the median salary in the us
as a whole which is 61 000 then it's
actually on the more highly compensated
side the con
is that while you might earn more money
than you would in some other careers
because of some of the challenges i
mentioned earlier in the video
like demanding work schedules and
difficulty to achieve work-life balance
a lot of consultants tend to get burned
out and leave after just a few years for
example
so here just to react to that so on the
salary side of course she is right yes
consulting in general is a
good and rather high paying career for
many of them and then it's also no
secret that the mbb consulting firms
are one of the firms that pay the
highest salaries right so you can expect
yourself being even at the
higher end of all the spectrum so yes of
course the salaries are high
but what she also rightfully explains is
that the demands are higher on you as
well
so you will have a less well work life
balance there will be quite a
significant amount of stress and
pressure on you
and yes some people do burn out and do
struggle
and it is also correct that after some
years many leave the consulting firm
though i would argue that this is not
only due to burnout in the work life
pressure
but also just for other career related
choices as well well at bcg
43 of the employees have been there for
less than two years and 77 have been
there for less than five years so
despite the pay
because of the lifestyle of consulting a
lot of consultants tend to leave after
just a few years now as a last pro
and flip side to that many of these
consultants leave their jobs because
they have an even better opportunity
whether it's a job at a different
company
or maybe it's an acceptance to a
prestigious business school whatever the
reason
having that consulting experience on
your resume makes you a very valuable
asset which is why so many people decide
to go into consulting in the first place
so yes agree with that consulting is a
great career choice and also does open
many doors of you
and especially now with an mbb
background these are of course kind of
household name consulting brands
and there are different firms that
really specifically look
out for these profiles so then higher so
yes if you have this background
it is a great career choice it can open
many doors for you
of course there are other choices other
paths you can go
that might provide you with great
opportunities as well but of course
at least from my experience what i have
seen this is something that might be a
path very worth going that's it guys i
hope you took some valuable information
out of there and if you have any
questions just leave me a comment below
in the comment section and i will do my
very best to answer
every single one if you took any value
out of this video please destroy the
like button for the youtube algorithm
and if you want to see more content like
that subscribe to my channel i'm
uploading at least
one new video every saturday on my
channel i talk about
my experiences being a former mckinsey
strategy consultant and i want to help
you to become successful in the first
years of your career and if you want to
see even more from me i also have an
instagram channel
my handle is firm learning and i also
have an email mailing list you can sign
up for that for even more content the
sign up link is below in the video
description
thank you guys for watching hope you're
all having a great day and see you next
saturday